[Music]
you're familiar with my work psycho
history every mathematician has read
your theory it's not a theory
it's the future of mankind expressed in
numbers
hey guys pete here today i'm gonna do
one more foundation video before the
first season premieres on september 24th
i'm going to look at the history of
isaac asimov's book series and the way
the tv show might change things in its
adaptation after watching and breaking
down all the teasers and trailers it
does seem that the show will have a
different feel but that might not be a
bad thing before we jump in there will
be some light spoilers as to what the
story's about so this is your chance to
leave if you were planning to go in cold
with that out of the way let's get
started
apple tv's foundation is based on the
seven novel series of the same name by
isaac asimov it was first published as a
series of eight stories in astounding
magazine from 1942 through 1950 then
those were collected and published as
three novels from 1951 through 1953
after writing foundation stories for
almost a decade asimov got tired of the
series and moved on to other things and
that was it for 30 years it was a
trilogy made up of the books foundation
foundation and empire and second
foundation the series was well received
if not commercially successful in 1966
at the world science fiction convention
it was the winner in the one time hugo
award best all-time series beating out
the lord of the rings and from there it
continued to gain popularity as more
people discovered it solidifying its
status as a classic for a really
important period in sci-fi by 1981
asimov's fans and publishers had been
pressuring him to revisit the series for
decades and politely he'd been telling
them no in that year the publishers
decided to entice him with an advance
worth 10 times his normal rate and he
agreed to write his first foundation
story in 32 years he continued where he
left off writing two sequels
foundation's edge and foundation in
earth both of which debuted on the new
york times bestseller list he also
revisited the robot series at this time
deciding to connect his two most popular
sci-fi series after he finished
foundation in earth he was unsure how he
wanted to finish the foundation story so
he went back and wrote two prequels
prelude the foundation and forward the
foundation providing an in-depth
backstory for harry selden and fleshing
out what life was like in the empire
before the fall for people on trantor
unfortunately asimov died in 1992 after
completing ford so when that was
released in 1993 it became the last
installment in the series foundation is
about the work of the mathematician
harry selden he developed a statistical
process that can predict future events
on the societal level in that work he
discovers that the galactic empire is in
the process of collapsing and that's
going to be the beginning of a 30 000
year period of chaos until the next
empire rises essentially it's too late
to stop that it's already been going on
for too long but he believes he can
shorten the period of time between the
empires to just 1 000 years
he creates the foundation to guide
things and to develop the second
galactic empire asimov came up with this
idea when he was 21 years old and he
pitched the idea of a future history of
the fall of an empire on the galactic
scale astounding stories editor john
campbell convinced him to make it an
ongoing series lasting a thousand years
to include the rise of the second empire
this opens the story up for a lot more
opportunities as the characters can look
at the past and look at human nature as
a way of navigating themselves through
the process of creating something new
psycho history is the hook but including
a plan that solves the central problem
scientifically means that he had to come
up with different ways to keep things
interesting no one who has power wants
to let go of it and the math is so
complicated that no one can actually
verify it the ruling class which i'll
come back to have an interest in not
believing in selden's warnings and his
decades worth of work is legitimately
difficult for them to understand also
psycho history can't predict the future
of an individual or what they might do
so overall no individual is all that
important over the course of the story
but in predicting these trends or events
that will affect everyone selden does
anticipate a series of crises that will
occur in those periods individuals will
have to rise to the occasion in order
for the foundation to continue to add
another layer psycho history won't work
if people know what's going to happen
after all if they did they might change
their behavior and that would throw
everything off so harry is able to
predict the inevitable crises but can't
prepare the foundation to face them it
comes down to what amounts to a series
of puzzles and personalities emerge at
the right time to assess the situation
and often do more than just follow the
plan
with its storied history and such a
captivating idea behind it you might be
wondering why you've never seen a screen
adaptation of the foundation series part
of the problem is the scope he set out
to write a story that was going to last
a thousand years this means that decades
pass in between each of the opening
stories introducing a new cast of
characters in each new installment it's
part of the appeal of the books in that
it allows the author to show the
different stages of development of the
new empire but it doesn't naturally lend
itself to the format of television shows
where characters are developed over a
multi-season series for an example harry
selden is only alive in the first 28
pages of the first book in the series
he'd been working on psycho history for
40 years so he's up there in age and the
next story occurs 50 years later after
the foundation was established so his
influence is driving the story his plan
is basically the main character but he's
no longer actively involved
since 1998 different studios tried to
adapt a story first as a movie and then
later as a tv show but nothing panned
out until now all that's to say that a
close adaptation isn't likely you could
make the argument that it would be
ill-advised considering the challenges
and after seeing the trailers it seems
like the series will be its own thing
based on the casting there are some
obvious changes in the gender of some of
the characters that are introduced early
edo demmerzelle salvor hardin and gal
dornik are all women in the show for
salvo and gal which i think they
actually changed to be pronounced scale
this doesn't really change much
considering what they do in the story it
seems like just a way to introduce some
female characters early since the first
book doesn't have any to speak of
demisel is more intriguing because this
is a character who has a connection to
the emperor cleon the first but in the
books he was already dead by the time
gail arrived on trantor i can't really
get into that character without spoilers
but cleon is the next big change we know
about in the second teaser they revealed
that there are clones of cleon that make
up a genetic dynasty there are three of
them at different ages at any given time
sharing a triple throne brother dawn
brother day and brother dusk from the
youngest to oldest this and some of the
other changes we'll discuss are an
effort to keep some characters in the
story across multiple seasons it's
towards the point i made earlier the tv
watching audience wants characters to be
invested in if you're changing things up
multiple times it becomes difficult to
follow and it's hard to care about what
happens to characters if you know they
aren't sticking around the showrunner
has said in interviews that they came up
with ways to have around 6 characters
stick around through the centuries for
that reason and we'll see how that plays
out the genetic dynasty might be a
welcome addition and it doesn't hurt to
have an actor like lee pace on the
roster we get a glimpse of how that
might develop with the casting of
brother dawn there are two different
actors for the role one very young which
means that different scenarios of their
ascension to the middle throne as
brother day can be covered that could
also work to fill in the time between
stories the first two stories in the
series cover gale's arrival on trantor
and the beginning of the foundation on a
planet in the periphery of the empire
called terminus gail meets with harry
selden and as far as what we've seen the
show seems to be sticking pretty closely
to harry's character this is a good sign
considering his plan in psycho history
is the backbone of everything it appears
they're going to be giving gail a lot
more to do and perhaps using her
backstory as a way to do some world
building she's from a small planet where
life is much different than it is for
someone who grew up in the capital from
the trailers we can see that she's going
to have a relationship with another
character who wasn't originally around
in this part of the story rage is a
character that harry meets in the
prequels when he's still a kid and he
ends up adopting him because of the time
that passes in the prequels he's already
grown and had a family and ends up dying
off planet before we get to the
beginning of the original trilogy
salvor hardin is born on terminus and
grows to adulthood as a member of the
foundation this is my favorite character
in the first book and the one that
highlights the strengths of the
structure of what asimov was going for
most of the terminus scenes in the
trailers appear to diverge quite a bit
from the original story and i just hope
the show's able to reproduce the same
effect at the reveal of the first crisis
the book pulled off this is what
originally hooked me into the story and
this was actually the first short story
that was published in relation to salver
the last thing we know for sure that's
different is the vault in the show the
vault is this mysterious hovering
structure that was already on terminus
when they arrived according to the
showrunner no one knows what it is
because it's surrounded by a null field
that keeps everyone away everyone except
salver who they say has a special
relationship with it the vault does
exist in the books and it's important as
things progress but there's no
resemblance to what we've seen in the
trailers so for now we'll just leave it
at that to wrap things up for me the
best parts of the story are how the
foundation adapts in the process of
building up its power also the different
stages it goes through that resemble
emerging empires from our history it all
makes sense because it's all human
although it's humans that have colonized
the galaxy and can hop between planets
there are a lot of great twists
considering the population have no idea
what the plan is and at least in the
book harry doesn't train or install any
psycho historians with the original
group on terminus that gave azimov a
clean slate to present situations and
introduce personalities that have to
come up with solutions when they're
facing the different crises it's a nice
setup it's a story that's got good bones
and there's a lot of potential for this
to become a good tv series and it's a
somewhat unique situation where you
wouldn't actually want them to do a
one-to-one adaptation as a sci-fi series
it's certainly influential most of the
things you like the people that made
them red foundation and once you get
into it you do see its influence all
throughout sci-fi i think that's a good
place to leave it i'm excited to see it
i hope they'll be able to hit those
things that make foundation great even
if they get there in a different way i'm
curious to hear what you think so let me
know in the comments and please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching i'll talk to
you soon